men who think we should outlaw abortion
forever
say hi
and who's opposed
neigh
i'm just playing i know i can't vote but
you know more's gonna be more
benedict cumberbatch uses his saturday
night live appearance to take a stand
the great writers are the cast of all
casts this season has been amazing
during snl's closing moments the dr
strange star and cast members wear
t-shirts supporting abortion rights and
roe v wade this comes amid headlines
surrounding the leaked supreme court
draft opinion which threatens to
overturn the landmark decision
1973 is written on the t-shirts the year
roe v wade was passed and made abortion
legal on a national scale this isn't
snl's only reference to the ongoing
controversy
well it's clear to me that we've reached
the limit of human knowledge we found
the
haircut unusual for snl's host benedict
actually appears in the opening sketch
poking fun at the leaked draft's
reference to laws that are centuries
years old
i started to think about abortion
don't you think we ought to make a law
against it
you mean like the law we have against
pointy shoes
we should make a law that would stand
the test of time so that hundreds and
hundreds of years from now they'll look
back and say no need to update this one
at all they nailed it back in 12 35.
later michael che chimes in on weekend
update i just don't get why republicans
are so against this i mean maybe don't
think of it as an abortion think of it
as a patriot storm in the uterus to
overturn the results of an unfair
pregnancy
these moments come after a week filled
with protests and celebs sharing their
concerns for the future of abortion
rights
getting an abortion is not easy making
that decision
is not easy following the leak whoopi
goldberg was one of the many stars with
a passionate stance on the matter we got
tired of tripping over women in
bathrooms public bathrooms who were
giving themselves abortions because
there was nowhere safe nowhere clean
nowhere to go
this law came about because people
wanted people to have somewhere safe and
somewhere clean it has nothing to do
with your religion this is not a
religious issue this is a human issue
now back to benedict
in the lead up to hosting for the second
time he explained to et what makes the
snl experience so special it's a real
right and it's it's one that once you're
on it just goes so fast it's like a
blink of an eye thing and it's gone and
there's no way of flexing that muscle or
just or trying your hand at it in any
other
in any other realm really so it's pretty
unique in that experience
[Music]